it's a big weekend for retro toys in las
vegas we have the die cast super con and
on sunday the toy and comic show it's
all happening at the plaza hotel and
here to tell us more is toy expert and
owner of the toy shack welcome back to
the show johnny jimenez good to see you
buddy you too jc my man how's it going
great man this is the longest running
show in las vegas wow this is uh we've
been in vegas for over 12 years it's
very family oriented we got about 20 30
guests coming through everybody from
mattel
uh we got uh butch patrick we have sean
crawford who was yak face and returning
the jedi uh we have william daniels who
was the voice of knight rider oh the guy
not the woo woo yeah the actual speaking
boy yeah
and a ton of wrestlers and and mayan
actors and something anarchy spin off
yeah our good friend noel g from fast
and furious he's been on this show yeah
you got a great guess yeah we're excited
so today and tomorrow nine to six kids
12 and under are free and there's a ton
of activities for everybody well let's
talk about some of the toys here first
off the the diecast supercon that's
focusing on matchbox cars and hot wheels
everything everything with wheels uh
diecast miniatures we have a ton of
exclusives this is an example of some of
the exclusives at the con
to room like there's uh tons of hot
wheel vendors starting from the
originals in 68 up until the modern
stuff okay i'm sure these people
watching right now that have hot wheels
or matchbox cars at home up in the attic
or in the basement if you're back east
are those cars worth some money which
should be what should we be looking for
the early ones up until 1975 have the
red lines on the wheels yes so those are
definitely the premiums but definitely
the
80s 90s stuff is all went up after covid
the collectible market had a huge surge
so everything from collectible cards
comics old figures has just quadrupled
in value batman's the big movie this
weekend what do we have here so this is
one of the classic amigos
this was huge in the 70s still very
collectible um the 80s stuff is just
went through the roof but you'll see a
lot of this there at the show and it's
great whether you're just collecting or
not you're kind of walking back and
nostalgic it's just takes you back to
your childhood you feel better it's like
therapy going no i know i know this is
my like getaway
uh some people like to go to bars i
might think it's you can you go get it
this is my fix we have to talk about
this one here because tell everyone the
story behind super mario brothers 3 this
was for regular nintendo or super
nintendo well that was a promo piece
that only came in a game system uh set
so what happened was i went to a guy's
house to buy some toys and he had some
nintendo power magazines i got excited
over there oh my gosh i remember those
yes and he said oh you like game systems
i just threw a ton of boxes in the
dumpster
so i was
five seconds later i was digging through
the dumpster and i found this sealed
game cartridge in there which is pretty
it's about a thousand dollar piece
because it's sealed yes because it's
sealed okay this is so cool i i i love
this guy right here if you don't know
this was from the tv show alf
great to come in the late 80s how much
is this is an alf telephone how much
does a toy like this go for about 150
it's got the hang tag steel it's it's a
really nice shape
but uh yeah for anybody for the younger
people out there this was the telephone
that we used before cell phones
you call your buddies you want to come
over and watch alf tonight this is great
man yeah yeah it's a lot of fun i mean
we really do it all and and if you
wanted something to do today and
tomorrow definitely join us bring your
toys down we also have psa that's there
and they'll be if you have autographs
that you want to get certified they'll
be there to certify them for you i'll be
there buying toys so if you got some
toys to sell or you need something
appraised and we'll have a ton of
celebrities and activities for everybody
johnny we love it of course johnny used
to be the toy expert on the pawn stars
that's right you recognize him and he's
got the toy shack down downtown
yeah friday and saturdays were open
until midnight so come visit us downtown
and we'll have a lot of fun love it real
quick the website to get tickets uh go
to house of cards on the instagram or
you can also check out some details on
vegas toy shack on facebook and uh but
yeah you will have a lot of info also on
there we'll have a link on your site as
well beautiful thank you johnny we
appreciate it this is so cool it's
almost time for the ac